Speaker 4: It's great to welcome to
the program today. Bill von Hippel,
who's a professor of psychology at the University
of Queensland in Australia and also author of the
book The Social Leap The New Evolutionary
Science of Who We Are, Where We Came From,
and What Makes US Happy. So great to have
you on today. I really appreciate it.
Speaker 5: Thanks for having me, David.
Speaker 4: So I mean, I guess to pick
somewhere to start, there's often conversations
about when, when we're humans modern and when
would we look at past humans and say, yeah,
at least physically and generally speaking,
that's the same sort of species that that is
us. But there's maybe a little bit less time
paid in popular culture to what was humanity like
at at sort of some of those earlier stages. So
maybe we go to the kind of rainforest to savannah
phase. Talk to us a little bit about what would
be the big differences we'd notice, I guess.
Speaker 5: Sure. So if you go back to when
we were still the same species
as our cousins, the chimpanzees.
So we're talking six or seven million
years ago living in the rainforest,
all the data that we have suggests that we would
look a lot like modern chimps. Not exactly,
but awfully close. And then when we left
the rainforest and moved to the savanna and
actually it was the rainforest that left us
it dry it out in the region that we were on.
But when we left, it moved to the savanna. We
were still probably very chimp like for a long
time. And in fact, if you fast forward the clock
about three million years to australopithecines,
you could see them standing next to a chimp. And
the primary difference between them would be that
the australopithecines can stand straight up,
that they're completely bipedal, but they they
look awfully a lot like a chimp. They are in their
structure and almost everything else about them.
It doesn't look like we're moving anything
towards humanity. It's not really until
about 1.7 million years ago, maybe two million
years ago, when we get to Homo erectus that we
start to see an ancestor who you would
expect to be on your side of the glass
at the zoo rather than on the other side.
Speaker 4: When we talk about modern humans,
it is the best science we have.
Still that that phase goes back
about two hundred and fifty thousand years.
Speaker 5: Yeah, that's that's a great number.
The downside, of course, is that there wasn't one
day where we were or weren't humans and then were
right, and so it's a very slow spread when you
look at fossils that are a little older than that.
You start to see pictures that don't look
a lot like modern humans, but just a few.
And when you look at fossils that are younger
than that, you even occasionally see things
that look a little archaic as well.
Speaker 4: There are many efforts made
by sometimes. I don't want to say modern
psychology like pejoratively, but but
by some modern psychologists, sometimes to explain
certain responses that we humans have today to
certain stimuli by telling stories about what
things would have been like when humans were on
the savanna. You know, the idea of the fight or
flight response, which we might have now in public
speaking? You often hear analogies to, well,
it's better to err on the side of if there
might be a lion coming to have sort of that
reaction. Another example is I recently spoke to
an expert on sleep paralysis and other conditions,
and we talked about the very common dream
of falling. And his idea was that may go
back to when we were in the trees, and there would
be an evolutionary advantage to having that kind
of startle response, even when it's only a
dream that you are falling because it might,
you might really be sort of falling out of a
tree. Those stories, how useful do you think they
really are in kind of thinking about our past?
Speaker 5: I think they're useful sometimes,
but they're really primarily useful in
developing hypotheses. And so if you think,
well, public speaking, maybe that's some sort
of ancient response to two lions or saber tooth
on the savanna, something like that. Well,
you need to explore that hypothesis. Say,
what does that tell us? Now, personally, I
don't think that would get you anywhere because
what was a bigger deal to our ancestors but was
no longer saber tooth on the. But the possibility
that our group might reject us and if ever this
is a chance to in my group, reject me all at
once is when I'm publicly speaking and in saying
something to everybody. If I say something wrong,
that's a great chance for them all to agree.
All right. Time to give Bill the heave ho,
which for our ancestors was a death sentence.
Speaker 4: That's interesting. That's interesting.
So and I think in you've written quite a bit about
how social behavior may be heavily dictated today
by our ancient ancestors and the evolutionary
pressures so that would be taking. It's the
same story that's often told. But it's really
applying more of a social interpretation to
it than a biological one, I guess.
Speaker 5: Absolutely. And then the
key is you need to find a way to try to test
it. And most of the research that we've done,
for example, and rejection, shows that our
responses are way stronger than they are to
the fear of predators and other physical stimuli.
A cliff, you might fall off something like that.
Speaker 4: The social rejection thing Jonathan
Hite has written about this a little bit
and also including in terms of religiosity, where
in the past, if you didn't go with the predominant
beliefs of the Klan, it might increase the odds
that you get rejected. And at the time it was much
more it was less trivial to be socially rejected,
maybe than it is now in terms of our survival.
We're now, one could argue, I don't really have to
be part of a church or I can even be a loner and
at least stay alive to a greater degree. Can
you talk a little bit about how that that
rejection risk has really changed over time?
Speaker 5: Well, the funny thing about that
rejection risk is, as you say, it hardly matters
anymore. Not only would you and I be just fine
if all of our friends decided they didn't
like us because we can still survive. But
even more importantly, we can move to a new
neighborhood and get a new set of friends.
But our ancestors didn't live like that. They
lived in groups that were relatively close,
so to speak. They broke up and regathered, but
in only within a relatively small clan. And so
they couldn't afford to risk their reputation
in the same way that you and I can today. And
this is the exact kind of evolutionary disconnect
that you were talking about earlier in our past,
it mattered a great deal. Now, it probably doesn't
matter as much, but there's nothing more painful
to people than rejection. And there's nothing
that drives us more than people making fun of us,
people doing the kinds of things that we see
our hunter gatherer ancestors do before they
reject a member, the group, they ostracize them.
They tease them, ostracizing and teasing make us
feel terrible because those ancestors who wouldn't
respond to that are the ones who. Then they took
the next step and they gave them the heave ho.
Speaker 4: Thinking still, along these lines,
I've heard folks like, for example, Jordan
Peterson, make the argument that the
possibility of a physical confrontation between
men. That's kind of how he would say always there
in the kind of background and socially important
is a driving factor in many ways for the
advancement of society in some way. And I say
this both as someone who I hope I'm representing
accurately what he said and I'm also not a
Peterson fanboy. I've been very critical of
many things, he said. I'm just interested in the
idea that there's this when men interact and.
Society and Western society, at least there's
the possibility that if things don't go well,
it may devolve into a physical confrontation.
Can you talk a little bit about whether that's
a conflict with what others say is the human
kind of proclivity for peaceful relations
rather than than violent relations? And see if
we can make a little bit of sense out of that.
Speaker 5: Yeah, that's a great question. So if
you look at our chimpanzee cousins, there are
about 500 times as likely to come into physical
conflict with other members of their group
than humans are. And so when we look at human
hunter-gatherers, so there's no police to stop,
you know, government. We see a ratio of 500 to
one for every one conflict we have, where we
fight with each other over something. They have
five hundred. But if you look at our chimpanzee
cousins, when they interact with members of
other groups now you see a one to one ratio.
There exactly is conflicted with members of
other groups. As we are, we are exactly as much
as they are. And so basically, we we've evolved to
be hyper cooperative. We work together incredibly
well. But that's primarily within our groups.
When we're looking at between group relationships,
they look a lot like chimpanzees did. And so
human males in particular are the ones who, when
the conflict comes, they tend to get into it. But
if you look at us within our groups, although we
formed shallower relationships than human females
do, on average, those shallow relationships allow
us to kind of form coalitions that dissipate and
then that reform later without any hard feelings.
But those coalitions almost never get formed when
we cross group boundaries, and that's where we see
the real violence that's part of our nature is
Speaker 4: the explanation for this, simply that
if you work together rather than fight with each
other, everybody's more likely to survive both as
a species and as a community and as an individual.
Speaker 5: Well, yes. And the reason that the
chimpanzees never crossed that particular Rubicon
is they never got to the point that we got to on
the savanna where there was enormous benefit to
be gained if everybody would cooperate. And so
when you look at chimpanzees psychology, they're
very clever. They do lots of things very well,
but they're fundamentally competitive with one
another. As a consequence, the individual goals
and the group goals never aligned. Whereas once
we move to the savanna, once we became bipedal and
now we could protect ourselves from predators. Now
our individual goals came into alignment with our
group goals, and as a consequence, it benefited
us individually to cooperate, and it made us
incredibly successful as an evolutionary story.
Speaker 4: That's very interesting in thinking
back. I mean, there's some characteristics that
now seem sort of trivial. Like, for example, I
cite, you know, you're wearing glasses, I wear
contact lenses. It's not a big deal. You know,
we adjust the prescription as needed. And we can
imagine a time in the past where that might have
conferred a much more significant disadvantage to
us, sort of as as individuals. If we think about
the humans that have been leaders in early
clans and humans that are leaders now, have
the characteristics changed significantly or have
they sort of remained the same from what we know?
Speaker 5: Well, it's it's a bit of a complicated
story because if you look at what we what our
ancestors were almost assuredly like for
the longest time, which is immediate return
hunter-gatherers, you eat today what you killed
today because you live pretty much on the equator
and meat rots pretty quickly. And so everybody
shares it all out in those societies. There are
no paramount leaders. There are leaders that come
and go as decisions are being made. And so maybe
you're the best hunter. And when it's time to
go on a hunt, we all turn to you and we say,
OK, David, what do you think? Where should we go
now? If you come up with an idea we don't like,
we still don't do it, but you carry a little
more weight, you have more prestige because
you're better at it. But now it comes time
to look for water or or find a new camp,
or try to decide how to deal with those
hostiles around on the other side of the ridge.
Somebody else might step forward with the best
plan. And so the one that makes leadership
effective in hunter gatherer societies is that
it's very distributed and it's very egalitarian.
We shifted away from that when we moved to when
we became agriculturalists, because now we can
store food and create stable coalitions, et
cetera. But interestingly, the modern world is
shifting back to that. And one way to look at this
disaster in Ukraine is that you've got a paramount
leader who nobody's told no to for a very long
time. And so it's harder for him to create and
assess whether an idea is good than it would be
for somebody who's democratically elected, who
who knows that they're at the will of the people
they can come and go, and their ideas are more
important than they have to be more persuasive.
Speaker 4: So there's this Jared Diamond has
written a little bit about, you know, when
the when the agricultural revolution happened,
you if you want to think about it very
mathematically, all of a sudden there were people
who started to be responsible for producing way
more calories than they needed. And that caloric
surplus sort of opened the door to specialization,
which includes people who raise kids and also
people who think and people who do politics
and think about law. And that type of thing
is that. Caloric surplus. The beginning of sort
of the modern idea of leadership and politicians.
Speaker 5: Very much so. And so once we became
sedentary and we could create a caloric surplus
that we could store, you have to be like I could
create a caloric surplus in the equator by killing
a giraffe. Right. But it's going to be gone.
Speaker 4: That's a key point. You're right.
Still being able to store it is a major thing.
Speaker 5: Yeah, exactly. So once we get to that
point where we can store it, we see society shifts
dramatically. Now, agriculture enable that for
most humans, but it wasn't always agriculture
there. For example, hunter-gatherers in the
Pacific Northwest knew where these big salmon
runs were going to come through. And so they could
create coalitions that could defend them from
other groups. They could catch all these salmon
to enough to last for a year, almost dry them out.
And now they've got food for a very long time. So
whenever you can create or source storable
sources of energy, you've got the basis to
build the kind of society that we have whereby you
can have specialization. Everybody doesn't have to
be a hunter gatherer. People can do whatever they
want because somebody else can be responsible for
generating that caloric surplus.
Speaker 1: It's often very
Speaker 4: there's a lot of black white writing
about all of these significant leaps forward,
like the agricultural revolution, the industrial
revolution and some, some folks at least seem
driven to assign good or bad to them overall,
which which seems so fraught and difficult.
I'm wondering if there's maybe a more overarching
theme that we could identify about all of these
leaps like, for example, a lot of these leaps
bring the opportunity for a lot of good, but also
things that are not so good. So, for example,
with agriculture, we could say, well,
all of the obvious good things and specialization
and potentially reducing hunger at the same time
you started seeing, you know, animal borne
disease. To some degree, you started seeing
inequality for the first time in terms
of, hey, a lot of people can actually
store the food for the future. Is the general
thing that there's always going to be some
aspects that are problematic with any advance.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I've never seen an advance that
was an unmitigated good. There's almost always
a cost. Now, sometimes we don't envision those
costs until later. And sometimes we don't envision
the benefits till later. The first agricultural is
live, shorter lives there, more disease
ridden and they were even they were
physically shorter than their hunter gatherer
ancestors because their diet wasn't as good.
So they actually suffered a lot for us to
benefit way later. You know, we were deal.
Would you take a deal to say, well, in a thousand
generations, things are going to be great? You'd
say, Well, no, thanks. I'll do something else. So
that's one side of the coin. I think the internet
is a good example. The other side of the coin,
it's democratized knowledge. It's made us more.
We can connect with each other more easily,
etc. But it's also done things like create
enormous amount of work as everybody in the world
sends me an email with a request for something.
It's created and used to be. They'd have to write
me a letter, and it was just too much effort.
Rice created all sorts of polarization as people
can create fake news sites, and literally your job
is to try to make it more persuasive. So with
all of these, when we enhance our ability to
communicate with each other, when we enhance
our ability to create and store new things,
we always there's almost always something that's
going to go wrong in that context. Humans tend to
be really good at fixing those things, and it's as
a rule we'd almost never want to go back and say,
OK, well, let's get rid of the internet. Let's
start hunting gathering again. That's right. Those
things don't happen. So we do a great job of
doing our best to fix them, but they're undeniably
the problems that accompany those changes.
Speaker 4: Yeah, one of the most interesting books
that addresses this specifically with the internet
is that I've read is Neil Postman's book tech
Napoli, where he talks about the sort of I
don't know if it's naivete, but the idea that.
Only sorting things out so that we only get
the good of any technology or advancement
is such an impossibility that it's almost not
even worth trying. It seems better to just
figure out how to deal with and manage the bad.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I think that's a great point.
And Adam Alter is a wonderful book called
Irresistible, where he also talks about
just social media and the technology that goes
with that. And again, all that stuff is great,
but then it turns out it's highly addictive.
And so it disrupts people's lives because they
start replacing their in-person interactions with
interactions with screens. And so you've got the
approach of technology, you've got the problems
that come when you just psychologically too
attached to these things and you no longer live
the kind of life we're actually evolved to live,
etc. Every single time you've there's pluses and
minuses and you have to find a way to navigate it.
Speaker 4: One of the points you make in
your book, if I understand it correctly,
is that following or letting our evolutionary
needs lead us leads to more happiness, all
else being equal. And I think that that's super
interesting. I'm also aware of ways in which it's
sometimes turned around and used in what I would
consider to be a negative way. Like, for example,
sometimes you will hear that type of argument used
by those against gay marriage and gay adoption,
et cetera, to say that's not going in the
direction that evolution leads us because to men
by themselves can't create offspring. And so it's
a sign that we should be anti-gay, for example, or
something like that, which I know is not your your
point. Can you talk a little bit about what you do
mean by happier by following evolutionary needs?
Speaker 5: Sure. So evolution pushes us to do the
things that help us survive and reproduce.
And so to the degree that we in the modern
world continue to do the things that helped
our ancestors survive and reproduce, they're
going to make us happy. And that means forming
good and long lasting relationships. That means
forming romantic sexual relationships. They're
on the gay point. You raise an interesting one.
There's actually good evidence for my colleague
Brendan Ziege that homosexuality also evolved
and that it serves purposes as well. And so the
same data applied whether you're gay or straight,
that evolution wants you to do the kinds of
things that were in your best interest. Now
the disconnects, the problems emerge when you get
to things like this, when you get to evolutionary
mismatches between our ancestral environment
and today. And so a good example would be
we evolved to be interested in sexual variety
because it helps you sort of spread your genes
into more than one basket. You're not taking
all putting all your bet on one person. But
variety was so rare in our ancestral environment
that it wasn't that disruptive to people's long
term monogamous relationships. Whereas variety
exists every day outside my door, I can see a new
person if I live in the city. And so it makes it
really hard to stay in a long term relationship.
If you're a city dweller in today's world,
because the evolved psychology of our ancestors,
was we responding to the fact that they probably
would know a hundred people in their entire lives?
There's no way they're encountering a million.
Speaker 4: And the reason that this was less
relevant, you say the variety was less
present. Was it just because we were in
relatively small groups that were homogenous?
Speaker 5: Yeah, yeah. We lived in groups between
20 and 60 people. We only mixed with people who
had our same accents, Boker, same language. If
we ran into somebody who didn't do that. We were
there was a risk that they were an enemy. We might
be friendly. We might get into a conflict. If we
were friendly, we might even use that as a chance
for men or women to switch groups to decrease
inbreeding, et cetera. But we spent our whole
lives in these small nomadic groups that didn't
run into that many different people. Mm hmm.
Speaker 4: One of the reactions that I often see
from 10, 11, 12 year olds when they, you know,
learn about evolution is it seems as though we've
stopped evolving to some degree. And of course,
you know, when we think about modern humans,
two hundred and fifty thousand years, we sort of
seemed to look the same and so on and so forth.
Can we think through a little bit more about
and this maybe this is more of a futurism type
question. What are the evolutionary pressures
now exerting influence on humans again,
now that we've solved a lot of the
things that used to kill us very early?
Speaker 5: Yeah, that's a great question.
So if we look at our at what are called
evolutionary sweeps, which are genes that
don't exist in the past and then suddenly sweep
through the population, we can see that in fact,
they've been more frequent in the last 10000
years than they were in the prior hundred
thousand years. So it may look like we stopped
evolving. Our bodies haven't changed much,
but there've been dramatic changes in serious ways
of learning to drink milk by producing the lactase
enzyme throughout our whole lives. Lots of things
like that. So evolution is still happening very
much at a rapid pace. But the forces on us are
now different. It used to be survival, and now
survival is kind of solved right for most of us.
We're very fortunate that that modern medicine
and agriculture have enabled us to survive, to
not have to worry about our survival. But sexual
reproduction is a big one. Our ancestors could
never disrupt the link between sexual activity
and reproduction. And so that guaranteed they'd
have lots of kids. We can now disrupt that thing
very easily, and evolution made us want to have
sex because when we were back in the day and. That
desire was important for reproduction, we didn't
understand how to create offspring, so we've not
we don't have an evolved desire to have kids. We
have an evolved desire to have sex and then evolve
tendency to be nurturing to those beings who come
along because of our sexual activity. Now that we
can separate out those two, I could easily imagine
a world not so far from now 30 40 generations
where there's just not that many humans because
most of us are not interested in having children.
Most of us are interested in doing other things.
Speaker 4: When we, I mean, humans, are
quite quite poor at making predictions about
what things are going to look like in the future.
Given that, what types of changes would
you be thinking about when we think about
500 years from now in terms of Homo sapiens,
Speaker 5: 500 years from now, I don't think
you'll see anything different physically.
Biologically, that's too fast. You'll see a
lot of cultural changes, and I have no idea what
those might be. You can imagine a world with free
energy and then nobody works for a living. You
can imagine lots of interesting possibilities.
But as far as us, our bodies and stuff starting
to look different or evolution started to
make us different. Even psychologically
from an evolutionary basis, you'll need
at least a minimum of a few thousand. Are
you going to start to see things in there?
It's probably going to have more to do with
who desires to reproduce and who doesn't.
And are there differences in the traits between
people who desire to reproduce and who don't?
Right now, those differences are primarily a
factor of how you live. If you're a city dweller,
you if you were kids and if you're a rural
person, if you're well-educated, you if you were
kids and if you're not. But those are lifestyle
factors that push you down a certain pathway.
What we don't know at all is what's the psychology
of somebody who likes to have lots of kids? And
what's the psychology of somebody who doesn't?
And might those psychology then actually play an
important role in our evolution going forward?
Speaker 4: Right, right? Fascinating. The book
is The Social Leap, the new evolutionary
science of who we are, where we came from,
and what makes us happy, where we come from and
what makes us happy. We've been speaking with the
book's author, Bill von Hippel. I can't tell you
how much I appreciate your time today. Thank you.
Speaker 5: Totally my pleasure.
Great to chat with you.